so we're gonna do a sort of proper year
in review of the David Pakman show
closer to the end of the year but I did
want to sort of let you know where
things are and where things are going in
2018 for the program it's been a pretty
complicated year so far and people who
have been following the show for some
time are aware of a lot of this stuff it
2017 has been a record year for us in
terms of audience more YouTube
subscribers than ever more podcast
downloads than ever TV and radio
affiliates more than ever on free speech
TV which broadcasts us on DirecTV and
Dish Network we went from four shows a
week now they are carrying all five of
our shows every single week so a lot of
really big growth a really significant
growth in terms of the audience size in
2017 but it hasn't been all good as many
of you know we had two huge crushing
defeats in terms of revenue at the
beginning of April of this year
YouTube D monetization began which
initially took 99% of our YouTube
revenue we've since recovered some of
that even though it's still something
that's impacting us to this day and then
about a month ago or maybe a month and a
half at this point we lost 100% of our
Amazon affiliate revenue you used to be
able to shop on Amazon through a link on
our website and we'd get a little bit of
a commission every time you bought
something Amazon totally shut that down
which was like another eight or ten
percent of our revenue so it's been a
complicated year but I want to tell you
what's on the on the table for 2018
number one there are a number of plans
in place for many more deep dive
investigations and even sort of more
academic mini-series on a lot of
important issues and part of that is
going to be because a part time producer
Noah Ferguson is going to be joining us
full-time and that's going to complement
the great work that Pat is doing it's
gonna complement what I'm doing and
it'll allow us to even further improve
the production value of the show more
long-form pieces and Noah's going to be
helping out on some of the business side
of the show as well so that's really
exciting for 2018 now in terms of
what's upcoming more specifically when
it comes to content and what you can do
now to help the show many things going
on number one if you go to
patreon.com/scishow you will see that
there's a new patreon goal of 2250
patrons and before we go to that Pat
you'll notice that it is so easy to use
the patreon platform you go to
patreon.com/scishow just click that
orange button or maybe pinkish orangish
pink god orange red that says become a
patron and you become a patron for as
little as $1 a month we have established
a new goal which I will read to you of
2250 patrons previously after we
achieved 2,000 patrons the next goal was
2500 but I've decided to create an
intermediate goal to create more of a
sense of urgency at 2,250 patrons we
will record edit and upload a multi-part
critical thinking miniseries first to
our patrons and eventually for full
distribution this is something that
we've been working on for a long time
actually and it's been about 90% done in
terms of the content and that last 10%
we just haven't gotten over the hump and
finished and part of putting this up as
a patreon goal 2250 is once we get to
2250 we're committed to doing it and I
think it's gonna get us to actually
complete this thing yeah I mean I want a
teaser now what are the topics we're
gonna focus on under the umbrella of
critical thinking of it very good that
was not a planned question by the way
from Pat last lest anybody be confused
I'm trying to think now logical
fallacies identifying good and bad
arguments uh it's it's like 12 or 15
different topics that we're going to be
covering in this miniseries it's gonna
be really really good when we reach 20
to 50 patrons we will do it and this is
a donor target not a money target right
so if you can contribute a dollar that
counts just as much towards the goal as
if you can contribute 10 or 50 or $100
okay really good miniseries a lot of
work but we're gonna do it
patreon.com slash david pakman show
number two in terms of what's going on
to get us to close out the year really
strongly 2018 calendars are here okay if
you go to david pakman.com slash
calendar 18 you'll see that there are
two op
for this calendar the calendar is
composed of 100% viewer created artwork
this is the fourth year in a row that we
are doing these calendars you can get
the calendar for free with a membership
autographed you can also get just a
calendar autographed or not autograph
get the orders in at david pakman.com
slash calendar 18 so that we can get
them to you before the end of the year
this is a really great calendar and if
you buy 11 months you get the 12 month
free that's right yeah you only pay for
11 months of the calendar but December
is a free count a free month that we're
including I don't know what that means
but it sounds pretty good so I'm
including it and then lastly the other
thing you can do to help us and this
costs nothing at all we are on a new
platform called steam it steam it is a
blockchain based sort of reputation
curation platform you can go to steam it
calm slash at-sign david pakman that's
st double e MIT dot-com sign up takes a
couple days for account approval right
now they're working on improving that
then just follow us an upvote what we
post and that you don't have to spend a
penny and you will actually be
supporting us financially and I
encourage you to engage with the
community there really a lot of great
content so a few different things going
on and I will come to you before the end
of the year with a full sort of Year in
Review love to look at top stories from
the year it's like most engagement all
that different stuff so we'll do that by
the end of the year with you and in the
meantime join our subreddit at david
pakman.com slash re d di t to submit
your suggestions for 2018 content